speak now to Elijah magir he's a
military and political analyst and joins
us from Brussels great to have you with
us so the US is convinced that Iran or
appears to be convinced that Iran is
behind this attack Iran of course denies
involvement it says it doesn't dictate
uh the actions to the groups that it may
well support what do you
think well I think the US is looking in
the wrong place because instead of
looking who is behind these attacks
although the Iraqis and announced that
they are behind it it should go towards
stopping the war in Gaza because we've
seen in Lebanon in Iraq and Yemen an
escalation of the type of weapons and
the attacks against the Israelis and
against the US that is considered in its
hand to put enough pressure on Israel by
just stopping the supply of weapons or
taking other measures that in the hand
of the Americans to stop this
War beyond that how might it respond it
has said that it will respond at a time
and a place of its
choosing well we have seen the isra the
Americans have responded in the past
against the Iraqis and against the uh
Syrian in both countries and against the
Yemen and all these response uh caused
further casualties but never stopped the
attack on the contrary
the attacks are increasing there are new
weapons introduced on all different
fronts and the attacks are targeting to
kill this time and cause further
casualties but it seems the Americans
are very happy to take further
casualties on behalf of Israel otherwise
America should exert more control over
the Israelis and ask them to stop this
war in uh response to the international
uh court of justice and this is not
happening and also the Americans have
sent Secret Letters to Iran asking its
intervention to stop his allies from
further attacking American troops uh in
bab Mand in along the Red Sea in Syria
Iraq and in Lebanon but Iran said well
you should stop the war on Gaza and
everything will stop so we've seen lack
of decision from the American side to
respond to the icj and to uh really do
what the Americans have committed to do
in controlling the security of the
Marian passages and the stability in the
Middle East because we are we are seeing
the US uh alienating its allies in the
region we've got Iraq already getting
upset about retaliatory tax on its soil
which bring casualties as youve said and
it's already sparked talks with the US
to withdraw as our correspond respondent
noted 2,500 US troops from Iraqi soil
they are involved in fighting isil Is it
wise that they leave that it that this
could leave lead to
that well it is because first of all the
Iraqi Army and hash shabi are very well
equipped and have enough experience in
fighting Isis or isil secondly the
Americans are not committed to the deal
they have made and the contract with the
Iraqi government that they are there to
fight Isis but not to kill Iraqi
Security Forces what they have done in
several occasions so the Americans are
violating the rule of the agreement this
is why the Iraqi government is forced
according to the I mean relying on a
decision by the Iraqi parliament in
January 2020 that the Iraqi forces the
Iraqi government will ask the US forces
to leave Iraq and if the Americans are
going to attack and kill more Iraqis
then this will give even more ammunition
for the opposition in Iraq to really
speed up the withdrawal of the US forces
which they don't want to do so at the
end of the day it seems America is
losing even further by accepting for the
war in Gaza to continue when the
solution is just stop Israel okay Elijah
Maga great to get your views thanks very
much for joining us there from
Brussels thank you